There is but i'll start again. Mrs.
Procreate you were born in scotland in
dumfries you maxwell to match your claim and
do you remember when you as
a nineteen 03 wasn't it. Yeah. Yes and you
remember when you were young girls your
first remembrance of dumfries it's go
away or those days it was very vague. You
know sure those days the noise my shoes
i know i know but all i can remember.
But we never had enough to eat. And those
days were pretty father my mother was
married twice a year so the stepfather
ship mother went to work for
a keep us and she went on the forty
two. When she died she had such
a struggle. Did you did your
father die or was he said i'm
a very very young the heart of
a rather odd place suddenly so you don't
remember your father and you know how to
back to work for us. What was
your stepfather like and what he
dreamed i was a bit of everything he was
a no hoper save for the
way and half the time
he would be here and work anyway as
it was many jobs to be got but i can
remember your child the churches used
to dress us. He really had nothing
and i always i can always remember
the catholic church as i was
a top of the hill. And someone to give
my sister feel under rotten buttons
and she walked in the way that i walked
away. So when she walked in the way of all
that was it the boy just treat someone
does have badly off. We were out and never
remember i have no pair of shoes till i was
twelve and then i fell down the stairs
with had you going to snow in the winter
heard you call and it was clogs where
clogs. But i would have much warmth
in them. No i was very very it's
a long time ago. But i can remember
getting things given to us.
And i'm not very tall. I've got
a quote given to me and it was right
and why i thought i must have been
a. You know they could fit me when
i was sixteen i thought it was.
Only singing to go you know had a new
dress and yet a life and we've had
a little and the food alone because we
used to go to free breakfast on my sunday
morning. Where was that
all i was led to know was
a church is to give the free breakfast
or not but we used to go to that free
breakfast or much on one front to go for
a free breakfast mind you but i know as i
remember the first day i started work i
draw
a thirteen and when i went home. There was
no food no house for my lunch. I thought
it was back to nothing that was there when
the war started. I was just before the
war. Yes only started
going to three and ten to
thirteen fourteen fifteen year.
Yes yes and my mother had
a very very hard struggle. My stepfather
went to india. Nay she got money.
I don't know whether she got money for
all of us. I enjoyed it's yes he was an
indian for about four years
coming back to him was he
a violent man. Well it could
be a birch who is more of
a. Well i will put it more of a sex many
a bit and stay in the house alone
mother always tried to shield us
and that wasn't i was very hard but they
showed all of us to look after you all
girls but you know three or
four roles and the youngest one
marlon died when i was fourteen and
they unleashed brothers and there was
good and they are me it was to get
a special food. It was younger than
he should have been. Do you know as
a homeless broken up. Do you remember
going to school. Yeah i remember going to
school and the smell right up to my knees.
I can remember that quite well i say
he's four and because half the time we
were never that school because my mother
was always
a little bit of cancer and
just from it could have done
something for us. She don't remember
when you left. I'm free. So how long
we were in doing proofs. Well i stayed
there are the family went to england after
that and i said. There
we're save for what's
a couple of years now and i went there and
i'm your mother went down to england. My
mother was there. You know that was dead
but the patri full of it. That's as. You
know you were in don't freeze all the time.
Yes i was at the rest of the family had
moved to manchester. They're still there.
The rest of them and i stay there for
a while. Work and all and mills. And
then i went to england i went to
service and then i shelled
out here must have been
a main street years where i can wait
here. Thinking back to your childhood in
shall we say but 1910 before the first world
war. What was it like in dumfries said
i was just saying and i had no work.
No. And i must work for anyone even
knows jesus and what i left out that
wasn't i was well for him but then i don't
care what anybody says if they're saying
everything was good. You know stupid you
know what was not true. What was it like
there by comparison to what it was like
here in nineteen twenty nine. She was
a lot of their step father was july.
And let me think back. You know i was in
service myself that was all sort of war
thinking about the
conditions when you were
a child and therefore the first world war
and how hard it was then was that harder
than it was here in 1920. Oh yes oh yes
yes i would say you got nothing from the
government and no state or no and no matter
how many kids you had you got nothing
for them and so it was one
struggle to better of here. Except
i mean just so we had a fear of
a bad spend here. You can't
live man and wife and
a child under twelve months time ancient
so weak and if i notice that but more than
my sister come right here. She's asked me
but never lived on twenty six shillings
a week i was shelling and i said no i've
ever lived. Own lane. She said no loss or
die and we lived on nine shillings.
Except when he got to extend five and
we'd have five weeks rent out of
that before we lived at all because
a give nothing for a child
under twelve months and i had
a bad time five in line and i went
to the doctor and they wrote out
a you know alleged fort i had to have and
the brought it right down to one and six
and all and lasted five months and we
would break down dizzy you know and
after that got past it but you're
supposed to get. I think was five
shillings for the child after that and
well still but he pushed because it was
formed six months of the groceries one and
six and for the meat and the rest was
retreating bread and milk no money and you
never got any money and you go in with
a room in the just gotten paid you couldn't
pay the rent. Did you get invicta trim
anywhere did you know we were fortunate
next door to it though i had
a friend that under house and shouldn't
rely on it like the rented church street
and she asked us to go and live down. I
had to look after her. That's the way i
don't know what would happen to
a lot of aid because it
wasn't funny but i went to
a meeting once. And i was always
interested in political things
and the chap sitting there
said we've come a long way in
a hundred years. And i
thought about that for
a minute and i said. How do you make that
out. You should. Well look what we have
today flash if you're only getting five
shows i mean where i get in five shillings
a week here and there's eureka stockade
there we get more than that. So how could
you be better off and
a hundred years had come nowhere but
my opinion you had come and it went
a hundred years when a man takes five six
a week to live on it when you had one do
you have two children then as no one was
winter which in getting for
him. Terrorists twelve month or
two. You just had to live and i
went to the baby show to them do
a baby show when he was six months and
i asked if you could have extra food
and should know john recruit was
a normal week but i had to feed him.
It is then realised i had to be able
to survive it was suffering when i just
can't work. I don't know some people are
good people with families
were better off and
a lot of life. Yes they were better off
just because so much for his child. I
wouldn't you know
a lot but so they got. And even
today the better off. Yes. Well
no you
a person who has lived through the depression
that was before the first world war
in scotland and that was the worst. Yeah
as you know i asked when we were kids.
There was nothing. You know we celebrate
can read and chat and of course my
stepfather was on that i was there for you
had anything and he had if you were to
go behind the fire. We had weather. And
all his own children were certainly over
the mosel you know were starving. How much
old and where the sea had servants and
you heard my mother and father. So that's
what i said to you know thirteen of yeah
. There will be no job to find enough.
Well one or small i missed sister she was
held as
a brother left home when it was nothing
to him and their next one was killed and
nine to fifteen and the others
were just we were all young then
delivery of them die and if you children
die in that yes i wish to died.
And was about to step step brothers and
sisters that he have them. Well even the
state but i just saw none of us. The one
that died he was killed and now that the
more and 1948 he was killed. So
none of that left four of us
all of us to have the other family
died. The last time we have
a tweet and then one died for her and how
did your mother manage to get enough food
for the lot of you. I don't know what to
tell the truth. Did i say she did it all.
She went out to work at you. Why she would
know that way. What did she do. She was
i mean there and and for you. She went back
away. And so soon. When she was i mean
babies. And when she was out of work.
Did she get out of work at all during
the time. Well i see my mother had
a baby about every teen months. Some of
them or let our team answer tween socio
went to work whatever was our side
to look after the others. So how did
. How old was the movie when she went out
of work i can tell you but i'm here to
young for to worry about think about these
so i think if i don't know if she had
one either. Every fifteen months or. I
think eighteen months is my story between
anyplace. And she would actually went
out in between the boobies yeah yeah.
This one just makes it
a bit an awful lot more difficult in unity
you when you were out here and it was
really hard. You were
living on nine shillings
a week to hold up backing in scotland an
it all new england. It would be manchester
your sister and sisters to just awesome.
Yeah in the depression of the thirties
depression. You said there were living
on twenty sexual acts of work for
a role that's what she said when she made
here she asked me if i'd ever live up
there for him and i had ever lived on
twenty six and so weak. And i should have
ever lived on nine years. She said no i
said well i have four years. And yet many
people who have spoken about that depression
has been harder there than here and
there with it. I can't see. Harder and i
sense you there's no comparison between
that internet and now you know it was
so much harder growl mean everybody was
hungry and when i was
a kid and everybody was angry. There's i
mean to say that was the one that many
jobs for anybody. They had to go
live to get any jobs. Just in
and. And i know the imperatives are and
things are very bad and australia. Our
tessanne hyde park london. We're exhorting
there and i'm pleased they're to fight
like hell for their conditions. Otherwise
i'd be down to the conditions of the
australian cooling coolie was the
name mentioned. Because here
. Single men were getting
five and sixpence
a week in england the dole in was twenty
two shillings per year but there's really
say anything unless you do you can compare
the prices as well as it. Yes well i
suppose. Well prices were very very
cheap very low in australia and
i know bread was. Fourpence halfpenny alive
and things like that. I've heard of one
of knight went through
a side of land. Yes that would be
true too. And that would put rather
a different complexion of. Oh well yeah.
But still five and sixpence. And the money
wasn't there. It was only
a paper coupon. Yeah and i can remember
that the paper coupon included one and
threepence worth of meat and the rest was
spread between milk and groceries and it
was a certainly
a curvy standard of living and that's what
the orators used to say in hyde park i
believe. Yeah right. Or you'll be down
to the standard of your story could be
. I mean surely. Yes. I wonder if
your good friend you give me close
for the baby you know all the
way to. Primary and longer then
i know you have the thought of it. The
head no. You know the way they do it.
Whatever the comparison to the day to
day. Comparison. I didn't 30s to do
today. There don't know the meaning of going
hungry today. Children don't know the
born. And you did you go hungry at all
during the depression here of the 1930s.
Well as i we are nine children. Oh my.
I know arrived here and nine to twenty
. Can see
a fish and i weep. Well i prefer money
compared to what we've got. As i was worth
it and i worked for eight
shillings for four years
a five before the result we
have a go and i got my wages
a person i had to spend on shoes.
That's one of my problems shoes
and that's where my money went to show you
who you couldn't go anywhere. And when
we landed here. We all had to pay and
when i was on the ship. I had no
money at all. There was two friends at their
bank at the hear their member spin off
and and that's what we had to land here
when we landed here which of the tickets
to the church shop at the right. Give us
a cup of tea in the centre so the way devil
you see and we didn't know where wide
receiver wore where do walk all the way
and i looked for it and they chose us for
showing me for a red not food just for
a red. So that's when i learned that
i would like to go over it again.
And i think you must receive a crew.